Galactic wars, festive cheer, and a very real
mission into outer space — this is everything
you need to know about the Guardians
of the Galaxy's resident underdog.
Cosmo the Spacedog's origins go all the way
back to 1957, over a decade before the first
iteration of Guardians of the Galaxy hit comic
book store shelves. During the Space Race,
Russia made history after adopting a
stray mongrel, whom they named Laika,
to be one of their test subjects. In
November of that year, Laika was launched
into space aboard the Sputnik 2 spacecraft,
becoming the first animal to orbit the Earth.
Laika's voyage in outer space was
not one she would return from,
however — she died after overheating
during the journey. The incident has
since become a talking point for animal
rights activists who protest animal testing.
Despite her tragic end, Laika's
legacy lives on in modern-day media.
Her fictionalized story was the subject of an
Eisner-winning graphic novel by Nick Abadzis,
while her name serves as the moniker for
the animation studio behind Coraline and
The Missing Link. In addition, Laika's story
also happened to inspire two comic book writers,
Dan Abnett and Andy Lanning, who created the
character of Cosmo for Marvel Comics in 2008.
Although Cosmo's first appearance in
the comics was alongside Richard Rider,
more commonly known as the superhero Nova,
Cosmo's backstory wasn't revealed until the
2008 comic book issue Guardians of the Galaxy
#1. Similar to Laika, Cosmo was a guinea pig
for the Soviet space program in the 1960s, though
their stories diverge when Cosmo is lost in orbit.
At some point, Cosmo's entire being was
altered by cosmic radiation. As a result,
he gained telekinetic powers. In addition to
being able to control objects with his mind,
Cosmo also has the ability to speak
telepathically, which he uses to
communicate with various characters in person
and from far away. This is often used for
comedic effect in the comics, as Cosmo's speech
is portrayed as broken, Russian-accented English.
This space mutation also gives Cosmo an extended
lifespan compared to the average dog, as well as
a host of potent psychic powers. Luckily,
Cosmo tends to use these powers for good.
Sometime after Cosmo acquires his powers, his
spacecraft drifts into Knowhere, which is the
severed head of a Celestial now serving as a kind
of planet in the Marvel universe. While Celestials
didn't appear in the MCU in full form until the
2021 film Eternals, Knowhere made its debut in
the first Guardians of the Galaxy film as the
home of Benicio del Toro's enigmatic Collector.
"How wonderful to meet in the flesh."
In the comics, Knowhere becomes the place
of residence for Cosmo the Spacedog,
and Nova #8 reveals that he has become
the planet's chief of security. As
part of his job keeping a watchful
eye over the citizens of Knowhere,
Cosmo uses a brain stem from the dead
Celestial to power the Continuum Cortex,
a teleportation device for any location in
the universe. When Nova arrives, Knowhere
becomes a base of the Nova Corps, who allow the
Guardians of the Galaxy to set up shop there.
Additionally, Cosmo's spacesuit is key to his
job of protecting the citizens of Knowhere.
Cosmo stores a Dimensional Envelope in his collar,
a device that creates a pocket dimension in which
he can safely hide the planet's inhabitants
in the event of an extraterrestrial attack.
Cosmo's work as chief of security
for Knowhere eventually leads him
to his first fateful meeting with the
Guardians of the Galaxy. Cosmo becomes
an adamant ally of the team in the
2008 run of Guardians of the Galaxy,
going so far as to suggest the team rename
themselves "The Retrievers" or "The K-Nine"
in his honor. However, their meeting required
some happenstance on the part of the Guardians.
Cosmo initially met Nova while he was on the
run from the Abyss, a cosmic entity that turns
humans into zombies. On Knowhere, Nova confronted
the Abyss with the help of Cosmo, who protected
its citizens with the Dimensional Envelope in
his collar. Afterward, Nova recommended to the
Guardians that they take up Knowhere as their
new headquarters. At the time, the Guardians
of the Galaxy consisted of Peter Quill, Gamora,
Rocket Raccoon, Drax, Groot, and Adam Warlock.
Cosmo eventually played a big role in The
Thanos Imperative, a comic book storyline
also helmed by Cosmo's creators, Dan Abnett and
Andy Lanning. After invaders from Earth-10011
come to Earth-616, the Guardians team up with
Thanos to stop the threat posed by an alternate
Lord Mar-Vell. The conflict eventually claims
the lives of many members of the Guardians,
including Adam Warlock, Drax, and Peter Quill,
the latter of whom charges Cosmo with
carrying on the legacy of the Guardians.
In the Guardians of the Galaxy Holiday Special,
fans took notice of Cosmo's early
interactions with Rocket Raccoon.
"Just concentrate, you stupid mutt… What?"
There's a little hostility between the two,
which will likely carry over to Guardians of
the Galaxy Vol. 3 — and this animosity also
has origins in the Marvel Comics. In the first
issue of the 2008 Guardians of the Galaxy run,
the two exchange unpleasantries upon
the Guardians' return to Knowhere.
Given that Rocket trusts pretty much nobody,
it makes sense that his relationship with
Cosmo is less than friendly. Nevertheless,
the two eventually warm up to each other,
becoming reluctant teammates during Rocket
Raccoon's solo comic series in 2014. In Rocket
Raccoon #6, Rocket goes through a lot of trouble
to secure Cosmo dog treat cupcakes, which
Cosmo deems as crucial to his survival.
As both Rocket and Cosmo are expected to
appear in Guardians of the Galaxy Vol. 3,
you can expect the dynamic between the two
anthropomorphic Guardians will be explored
more deeply. That's especially true considering
that the new film will, according to James Gunn,
delve into Rocket Raccoon's life and
origins. Since a confrontation with
the High Evolutionary is on the horizon,
the humanity of anthropomorphized animals
will likely play a big role in this third
chapter of the MCU's Guardians trilogy.
Peter Quill's death at the end of "The Thanos
Imperative" storyline leads to a cataclysmic shift
in the cosmic side of the Marvel Universe. Tasked
with carrying on the legacy of the Guardians,
Cosmo is responsible for bringing together some
of the strongest beings in the universe to fulfill
Quill's original dream. This new team assembled by
Cosmo debuts in the 2011 mini-series Annihilators,
consisting of Beta Ray Bill, the Silver Surfer,
Ronan the Accuser, Quasar, Gladiator, and Ikon.
Conflict soon arises between the assembled heroes
and anti-heroes, who are reluctant to carry out
Quill's vision. Still, Cosmo is determined to keep
this group together. He offers them the mission of
dealing with the Dire Wraiths, who have recently
broken out of their imprisonment in the Dark
Nebula. Cosmo doesn't reappear until Annihilators
#4 after the team has successfully dealt with
the Dire Wraith threat, at which point they
return to Knowhere, ready for another mission.
Of course, it speaks to Cosmo's influence
in the Marvel universe that he's able
to gather a team that is so stacked
with powerful intergalactic warriors.
Becoming the Nick Fury of the Annihilators
is far from the highest stakes Cosmo has
been involved with in the comics. Cosmo's
creators, Dan Abnett and Andy Lanning,
also helmed the crossover storyline "War
of Kings," which revolves around a conflict
between the Kree Empire and the Shi'ar. The war
not only draws in the Guardians of the Galaxy,
but also the Nova Corps, Inhumans, and several
other cosmic armies. Cosmo's role in this
storyline gives him an opportunity to interact
with two underrated members of the Guardians.
After losing track of Peter Quill during a
fight, Mantis telepathically contacts Cosmo,
asking him to teleport them to Peter's location
with the Continuum Cortex. Cosmo later continues
to help Mantis and Moondragon, another notable
Marvel telepath, attempting to stop the war.
However, when the space pirate Starjammers
bring the war to Knowhere, Cosmo is forced
to fight — one of the very few moments in
which Cosmo gets involved in the action.
"I think I shall call him… Adam."
Guardians of the Galaxy Vol. 3 features the
debut of Adam Warlock, an extremely powerful
character in the Marvel universe. Warlock is
a humanoid android specifically crafted to be
the "perfect" human — and at one point, he comes
into conflict with Cosmo the Spacedog himself.
In Guardians of the Galaxy #19, the Guardians
find themselves in a future ruled by Adam
Warlock's villainous alter-ego, Magus. During
this issue, the Guardians become afflicted by
trouble with the timelines, and Cosmo temporarily
becomes a puppy. They're later reverted back to
their normal forms by Kang the Conqueror,
but Cosmo doesn't last long after that.
When Adam Warlock loses control of Magus and
ends up fighting the Guardians, he ends up
killing not only Cosmo but Gamora, Phyla-Vell,
and many other Guardians. Despite their losses,
Star-Lord suppresses Magus and kills
him before returning to Knowhere as
a smaller team. Thankfully, the fallen are
revealed to be alive several issues later.
Cosmo first appeared in live-action in the
2014 film Guardians of the Galaxy. Written
and directed by James Gunn, the film is mainly
inspired by the 2008 iteration of the team,
which includes Peter Quill, Rocket Raccoon,
Groot, Gamora, and Drax. Guardians features
an extended sequence on Knowhere, where Tivan
the Collector resides with his museum of cosmic
memorabilia. One of those prized possessions
is none other than Cosmo the Spacedog.
Cosmo plays basically no part
in the events on Knowhere,
as the Guardians attempt to sell the Power
Stone to the Collector before the arrival of
Ronan the Accuser. The Collector doesn't
appear again until a post-credits scene,
in which he is seen sitting with
Cosmo in the wreckage of his home.
"What do you let it lick
you like that, for? Gross."
Cosmo also made an appearance in Season 1
of What If…?, an animated series on Disney+
examining alternate timelines within
the Marvel Cinematic Universe's canon.
One of those timelines finds T'Challa
taking Peter Quill's place as Star-Lord,
facing off against a corrupted
Tivan. After T'Challa defeats him,
Cosmo is freed by the Collector's former
slave and taken in as a pet by Yondu.
The Guardians of the Galaxy Holiday
Special gives Cosmo an upgraded role
with the current Guardians team. Early
in the special, it's revealed that the
Guardians have purchased Knowhere from the
Collector and are using it as a home base,
which aligns with Knowhere's function in the
comics. Subsequently, Cosmo the Spacedog is
now a de-facto member of the team, helping
them make touch-ups to their headquarters.
Just like in the comics, Cosmo and Rocket
butt heads over their mundane work,
but this story takes a backseat
to Drax and Mantis' attempts to
save Peter Quill's Christmas.
Cosmo is voiced by Maria Bakalova
in both the Guardians of the Galaxy
Holiday Special and Guardians of the
Galaxy Vol. 3, marking the first and
only instance in which the Guardians'
space dog has been portrayed as female.
Although fans have yet to see the
next chapter in the Guardians of the
Galaxy's adventures in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe, the end is certainly nigh. James
Gunn has adequately prepared fans for the
heartbreaking final entry in the trilogy,
implying that it will act as a send-off for
the current iteration of the Guardians team.
Given that it's unlikely the entire team will
be killed off, some of the new characters
debuting in Guardians of the Galaxy Vol. 3
may well become future Guardians in the MCU.
Cosmo and Adam Warlock, for example, may play
large roles in future films such as Avengers:
Secret Wars or even the Nova project rumored to
be in the works at Marvel Studios. Either way,
here's hoping for more adventures
starring Marvel's finest canine cosmonaut.